[Music]
[Applause]
all right welcome to awesome comics your
one-stop shop for everything comic book
entertainment and all you not
entertained regretted that regretted
that as soon as that happen
hi I'm your host today I oughta wait and
I'm here with two lovely people who will
be battling today's show for the Star
Wars prequels do they suck yay nay let's
find out all right over here new to the
show Jason hi welcome was very awkward
being here what side are you debating
today I hate the Star Wars prequels
what's wrong with you oh no actually
actually I am for the Star Wars
oh thank God I thought there was a huge
booking mistake
short of a billionaire for do you have a
favorite you know and it's really funny
because everyone I talked to after like
the span of time has happened my
favorites the second one with no family
like everyone hates that make someone
that's the mode that's fine but I love
that one I think it's fun too alright
alright and this scruffy-looking
nerf-herder over here Jim you know them
you love them back again yeah yeah and
so you're fighting for farmers are you
saying well that's what was inside today
it's really don't feel like that was ah
alright alright let's get into it right
now
um let's start off with our first topic
the special effects or CGI AUSA prequel
thank you go ahead Jim um I think
there's no contest the originals are way
they hold up better and the preschool
the practical the fragile effects way
better than the big cartoon that the
prequels were I mean even at the time I
know that the the effects were super
advanced and that was his whole goal was
like I have to wait until the effects
are you know the technology is there I
can create this technology to make the
world that I want to make but it's so
artificial and felt so on
real that there was no way to really
immerse yourself in the world or in the
characters because every shot was like
they're not actually there they're just
standing on a green screen they're not
interacting with real things and there's
so much going on that it totally
detracts from what should be the focus
is the characters and what's going on
there's like you know it's so boring in
dull it's like throw a couple of robots
in the background fighting or something
and you know or some clowning around
some alien steps and you know that
would be funny the tracks from the fact
that these two characters have no
chemistry what's away yeah so I guess
maybe let's pose a character CGI
question for you popping Yoda CGI you
puppet you it away I can't argue that
yeah I definitely prefer puppet Yoda
yeah but so what did you feel about the
CGI burn you can see that suppose matte
paintings kind of rewatch those matte
paintings in every scene and they're
kind of lame in a kind of wait a minute
not moving yeah yes the CG is kind of a
little bit hammy and all that stuff at
least there's movement stuff going on
look at a lot of the scenes in the
Jabba's palace the snow base their tiny
little rooms because they're nothing but
it's set
everything is so closed in Cloud City
they had two years later add in stuff
going on outside to make it look like
it's even alive now I understand
constraints and I understand time and I
understand all that but I get you if
over budget yeah yeah but it felt so
constricting every scene was just so
constricting now don't get me wrong your
scenes on Hoth where like Han and Luke
are out there and it's like this open
vast area looks really really cool but I
felt the same way happened on other
scenes from the prequels anytime there
in a town it felt like a town it didn't
feel like this tiny little set where you
know oh look there's three people there
that's all we can do you know the
cantina was great but you only saw bits
and pieces here and there you didn't get
to see like this full-on great view of
it and I think yes GG has its flaws what
question
there's
a lot of characters will look stupid
nowadays you know look at stuff that
came out in the 80s that was CG yeah and
but you have movies now like The
Avengers where the entire city scene and
the entire army is teaching and people
flock and love it but strangely when you
have an entire army of the clones which
are all CG people like not likely it
doesn't look like crap it actually looks
very good it's done very well it's just
I think this initial hatred it does it
CG and practical effects sometimes works
sometimes don't when you see you know a
TIE fighter blow up and you kind of see
the peaceful kind of hanging there for a
few second it's like it takes me out of
it but then again that's also the
problem with the advent of DVD DVD
cleans everything up you can go frame by
frame and find every little flaw yeah I
would say though that because we have
such advancement in film technology now
that when you see something CG and you
recognize it right away a CG it almost
takes you out just the same way so I
think that was one of those things maybe
too that was happening as well no I do I
do I find let me run the Columbia no
like I can't you why can't you make one
kinkle and true pursuit and you got a
guy in it and yeah applicative like why
do you have to make a CG clone trooper
you know any money you can understand
you need to create an alien andressa
mundane amount of money though in the
long run of having to pay an animator to
spend like 60 hours we're coming I have
in fact that's my Friday night bang with
Ringo Starr gets lit yeah I think it I
think it definitely speaks to also
there's there's a reason why we're going
back more to direct cool effects and
makeup effects and actual sex and actual
you know it stands for off time stuff
like that right it does look better it's
I mean you it adds some weight to what
you're actually seeing on film if you
can if you're looking at it you know
that that's a real thing
then you're a little bit more invested
in that actual world if you look at it
something you know everything is
artificial it doesn't hold as much
weight no form of
corer standpoint I'm a huge horror nut I
am all for practical effects over CG
when someone gets their head lopped off
and it hits the wall I want to see that
fake head laughs well not some fake CJ
face hit and slide down but when it's
something like Star Wars for me I get
lost in the world itself if and I think
maybe that's where the difference comes
in when I went to see the prequels sl3
in the theaters and every time I went I
got lost in it I didn't sit there and
watch it going oh this is the new Star
Wars film I'm going to check out this
and I'm going to look for this and I'm
gonna look for that and I think a lot of
people did that I think a lot of people
forgot to just lose themselves in the
movie and yes your sparks that will take
you out but that's the same thing of the
original theory there's parts that will
take you out if you let it
hmm and every time I want to see it I'd
lose myself in it I'd forget that I'm
watching a movie and I see the sprawling
it's like fields and everything even
when Natalie Portman and Hayden
Christensen are rolling down a hill and
I'm like oh we're out fit I think
everyone can agree her her costume
designs in her hair designs makeup
design but I'm a doll with all of that
done that bit of regret anyways I went
for a layered look today sorry ray I
mean for me that's what it was I got
lost in the movies I didn't go into it
you know thinking oh look these are
going to be like the originals and I
think that's what happens to a lot of
people as they compare to the originals
and they forget that these are their own
things yeah well that's why I wanted to
I think you have a unique perspective I
because you guy grew up we saw the
original films in the theater well I
just and I just see the original mostly
girls born from sake
yeah but you're never seeing but you
remember seeing at least probably Empire
oh yeah like the Eliminator and that
effect of growing up with those films
mm-hmm you know so you're not like
you're not a millennial who grew up only
seeing the prequel set up like that so
that don't move on to our final topic
that I don't know yeah that was the
other thing though when I was a kid and
we want students Peters like oh my god
every time I went to see it in theaters
for the prequels the kids were the
anyway the adults were kind of mocking
it and laughing at it but the kids were
having a blast
Yoda pulls out that sword the lightsaber
and quite Dooku yes you're slipping
around like a monkey but the kids loved
it
okay it's better than the old guys going
in and I get arguing I said I think we
forget that it's supposed to be mainly
for kids and yes there's politics and
all that stuff but when there's the
action the kids love it and I think
that's what's forgotten is that as
adults were like too harsh on it too
harsh we gotta remember it's the kids
that should be enjoying it not us I mean
okay Wow so to be here to say that I'm
you know our hatred shouldn't overshadow
what the kids enjoy right you know yeah
but the original ID the writ when the
original was truly released it was for
kids but kids and adult just enjoy her
for sure I believe it was Liz Lemon who
said the Star Wars everyone has seen the
Star Wars except the actors because they
lived it should be for all and I think
yeah focusing on kids right
yeah what about the ginger but that's
I'm saying is that I think it should be
for everyone show us as jaded adults
right we don't look at it as a kid we
live as an adult no we're like you know
and I just felt back in that kid mode
McCalla nothing fun you
and I was going to say let's move on to
our final topic of like what the France
of what the prequels have done for the
franchise I have a whole ruined it
way to go it ruined it for me and that
I'm not going I can go as far as to say
like I would ruin my childhood it
wouldn't but absolutely it took
me out of those films took me out of the
Star Wars universe they didn't feel like
they fit they feel they felt like
completely separate it felt like a
completely separate universe and
different characters and stuff like that
it didn't feel like it
it meshed it all into the original
trilogy so for a long time I can't was
like yeah I was I was more of a guy I
went from avid Star Wars to him to kind
of a closeted horse pan and I feel like
with the recent films and stuff like
that I feel a little bit more like I can
be a Star Wars fan again like you know
like I well it's kind of that they're
feeling more like Star Wars films the
films that are coming out now and partly
because it's harking back to that
they're you know they can there's CGI
but there's a good marriage between
practical effects and real things and I
don't know I can understand though your
point about the younger generation
growing up and that's what they have
like that's what they grew up with and
if I was you know a kid growing up with
that I probably would feel the same way
like like alright yeah I understand like
this is the Star Wars I grew up with but
they just don't hold up I think as you
get older I don't think you're going to
look at it within the same eyes as you
will the original trilogy has really
lasted the test of time you know it's
over 30 years that these films on light
well 40 years Morgan trello but having
that you know adding said that you're
like I do understand that you know like
the younger generation I'm curious to
see though if that continues or so of
those films really hold up or if they're
going to look back on it and be like
damn how these really don't hold up to
the
that are coming out now even after the
original agility um one thing I want to
bring up about that is look at movies
that are considered classics
Frankenstein gray I'm mainly going down
horror because that's what I really yeah
Dracula Frankenstein all that stuff
rewatch them they haven't aged
incredibly well but they're considered
classics why because they were some of
the first that did it or it's it because
everyone looks at them and they're told
they're classic so therefore they look
at it as a classic they don't look at it
from the actual perspective that we look
at modern films you know the Wolfman I
there's a scene where they're all
crowded around the tree looking at a
body when there's a body right behind
them like one of them Oh horrible like
horrible writing horrible effects but
it's considered a classic and god forbid
you see anything negative to it and Star
Wars is kind of another one of those I'm
not saying it's as bad as that but it's
got as flaws in this guy's mistakes but
god forbid you say that no I think that
we can test that there's lot of mistakes
in in the earlier films absolutely but
they're better crafted films they're
actually you know and they were well
made and not directed by Lucas exactly
oh the first one which was is
confidently made but it isn't it is in
the strongest of the original three my
son who's 20 to kind of mold he grew up
with the Star Wars prequels and he
watched the old one and he's read every
single novel and he's read every cut
well almost all the comics like he's an
actual like collector of the novels in
the expanded universe and all that stuff
he loves the prequels because that's
what he grew up with and he's been
looking back on him now he still really
enjoys them so do they hold up I as a
boulder that truly comes into play we're
going to look at it we're going to find
all the things we find really stupid
about it kids are going to look at it
like oh my god that was awesome
think about how many crappy movies we
watched like when we were kids
then we'll look back me I gotta love
that movie the explorers is great no no
no and I do I love the explorers but oh
my god it's not all that great yeah and
I think Star Wars changed the face of
moviemaking it did a whole lot
or it but I think a lot of times that
overshadows you know puppet Yoda
flopping around in a backpack well
Luke's doing flips you know it's neat
but at the same time it's a frickin
puppet going i prefer that though did
did you know kind of fluid I was
flipping around all over the place well
they're both flopping around yeah I
couldn't find a happy medium on out of
there yeah there wasn't like a like a
middle ground it's hard to have
something that's that small and that
like knowledge more like every it's hard
to do him justice in every facet sure
but for me what the prequels brought was
a great cartoon series a dozen in one
great novels a dozen in one great comic
books people say that the prequels like
destroyed the franchise hell no we got
so many spin-offs from that novels and
comics and like video games and
everything after that it kept it going
and kept the momentum flowing and if it
wasn't for those we probably wouldn't
have as much momentum and gotten the
force awakens
you know and people are harkening about
how great the force awakens is well
that's because you have all the same
characters from the originals wow that's
really original bring back everyone
everyone already knows and all we're
doing is flooding with nostalgia excuse
me bb-8 is amazing little wider phones
up cop I never thought I have ecstasy
force awakens because it doesn't
interest well the conversation is to be
continued because when you see bb-8 I
know you're gonna be like you know what
we ain't issues like a soccer ball
nobody wanna go flying no no he'll just
roll with it it's magnetic you're
kidding me Aaron little guilty now if
people wanted to start on Star Wars
comics do you have any suggestions as to
where they could kind of start or any
good runs that you know us oh yeah like
oh my god dark forces dark empire dark
Empire yeah oh my god sinful out there
right now and a decade burger great
because that's just one of those where
it really brings them decided okay
because that that continues those story
with those characters
original character you say like that
doesn't interest you yes but I also like
natural over public pickup okay
especially there's a character named
Jory which is my wife's name actually
spelled the same actually one of my
favorite novels is Darth Bane series
that's a phenomenal series that wasn't I
wasn't acute into the comic series
because they're so expensive
all over the place novels were a lot
easier for me
we at Darth Bane phenomenal that's a
really good one it's dark it shows how
the Sith went from being a giant academy
to just being down to just master and
student great awesome awesome
well guys um we'll go ahead and wrap
this up where can we find you on social
media if people want to connect with you
I'm not social I hate people computers
um I have a website called force to
buing calm I mean my friends we write
reviews horror movies sell tech space
don't look for videos don't think we're
all neat and flashy like these people
these guys are good we're terrible and a
lot of it's not safe for work we have a
lot of naughty language and sexual talk
and please be careful that's a good
shake of that action what about you I
could find me on Facebook at James Jim J
rot and yeah my channel awesome and many
aspects that's right yeah you can always
catch up here at the channel awesome go
ahead and like the awesome comics
Facebook as well we put up an exclusive
Facebook video for you guys every
Thursday so make sure and go ahead and
get that alike thank you for liking this
video if you want to see more content go
ahead and let us know in the comments
down below and let us know what the
prequels did for you in the comments did
you like them cuz you're not like them
are you looking forward to a certain
rogue one story I know I am so let us
know in the comments down below
II think and yeah well we'll talk to you
guys on is the next page
yes
you
[Applause]